[Music]
welcome back developers Jeff here and
I'm joined once again by a friend halfa
from pivotal alpha is here to tell us
about how to handle monitoring and
logging to our Cloud Foundry
applications last time we were together
we talked about how to monitor our
infrastructure but now we're talking
about the foundry what's next alpha the
next step is connecting the Cloud
Foundry logging and metrics pipeline
also called lago gator the spec driver
so this would be data ranging from
running application logs to Health
metrics such as container CPU usage
that's right Jeff laden gator is
designed to hook up to external data
sinks which Cloud Foundry calls nozzles
the Statue ever knows what connects to
the pipeline if you UDP today
potentially switching to TCP in the
future and receives up lossy schema data
from Cloud Foundry to prevent backups in
the system the nozzle can be scaled
horizontally as necessary to handle
increase the log traffic that's why we
and I mean a great team for pivotal and
Google including us developed a stack
driver nozzle this open source project
connects the logger Gator to stackdriver
logging in metrics it is available on
github as part of our stack driver tools
Bosch release alpha can you show us how
to get set up with the nozzle let's do
it
first we need it in row our DCP project
in the spectra for metrics API and
ensure our quotas are set to the
proprietary tada our github deploying
the nozzle can be done by modifying a
bas-reliefs or deploying the tiles
through PCF operations manager let's use
the Bosh release for this sounds good to
deploy to stash our douzo first upload
the latest release from a github repo to
our Bosh director and then add the
release to the manifest now create a
pool of nozzles with some light
configuration to connect your aggregator
in our Bosh manifest this sounds like a
great time for and here's one I prepared
earlier let's paste it in for now well
have a more detailed example and I'll
get help linked into the description
below
that's also rolling the roads fastest
Bosch deploy voila
so we've got logging let's prove it
vlogs generated by our application are
streamed into the stackdriver logging
console we can see the logs appear in
near-real-time
as they happen the logs we generated
show up with detailed metadata related
to the GCE instance and the Cloud
Foundry application one great use of
this is to filter down to logs from a
specific application streaming logs can
be useful but often you want to perform
aggregations and analysis on your data
this can be done in real time by
creating a log sink from stackdriver
into bigquery every message that CF
generates maintains a structure which we
can use in our analysis let's see what
unique user agents I've hit Eric I've
found you today sure let me test my
minimal bigquery knowledge so we'll want
to filter by HTTP start stop events and
I'm gonna add a simple group by
statement
okay just find it down here here's that
structure we talked about and I'll just
go ahead and select that value so we can
see it and there you go there's a list
of all the user agents that hit our
foundry today that's awesome so now we
have a full logging pipeline backed by
CF stat driver and Google bigquery so
let's take a look at those metrics we've
been talking about why don't we open up
Statuary monitoring and take a look at
our user created dashboard this is
another cooking show moment but the
creation process was just at chard click
click click so we'll just go ahead and
skip it CF exposes a ton of metrics on
the health of your calendar and
applications the stretch Evan also
handles these metrics and sends them in
just action we're monitoring this
dashboard goes beyond what we can
measure at the VM level and gives us a
look and get a huge number of metrics
that Cottage exposes on each container
cool so we can see information like CPU
activity of an application and we can do
that at the space org or even
application level this sort of view lets
operators and developers better
understand their applications and make
scaling decisions a user can also create
alerts to detect abnormalities and
that's application monitoring with Cloud
Foundry and stack driver and thanks for
watching our series on cloud foundry and
stack driver for more information
about stackdriver and Cloud Foundry on
Google cloud platform check out the
description check out our last video on
host muttering with stackdriver
and be sure to check out our playlists
for more videos on pivotal Cloud Foundry
don't forget to subscribe